thanks everyone for coming so at the
office of digital dissemination the
approach we've always taken to digital
dissemination is one of platform
neutrality which sounds like a fancy
term but really what that means is that
when we work with Sheree Carter galvan
who I see here and her colleagues at the
Office of General Counsel to negotiate
agreements for platforms those
agreements are always non-exclusive all
right so what does that mean that means
on one hand that it gives us the richest
set of options to support faculty in
what they envisioned so this allowed us
about five years ago to work with the
Divinity School to use the open-source
Drupal platform to publish teaching
materials to the world with the Miroslav
Volf faith and globalization course when
we think about the open yo courses
initiative it allows us to disseminate
teaching materials on youtube and itunes
in addition to diana's open your courses
yell that edu home website and now as we
think about the future so Paul was just
talking about how will be using Coursera
to start launching MOOCs in early 2014
but again we know that this is in no way
the end game we know there will be more
platforms more technologies and most
importantly faculty will have more
amazing ideas for how they want to
disseminate their teaching materials
that will not fit into what we now
consider this packaged MOOC format one
of those faculty recently contacted
craig and i was YG Dimock who's going to
speak momentarily about an idea that she
has for disseminating teaching materials
that wouldn't be appropriate for a MOOC
platform whether that platform is
Coursera or the open EDX platform out of
Stanford MIT and Harvard but really
needs to rely on other open source tools
whether that be Drupal or WordPress and
call on some of the other broad
dissemination tools like youtube and
itunes so it's a way of sharing our
teaching materials in the world but not
in the way that I think is Diana
described as the coin of the realm now
with the MOOC format so at the core of
this is working with faculty whether
it's at the college the graduate of
professional schools to think about the
goals for that initiative how do you
want to share your teaching materials
who do you want to reach and then let's
look at this broad set of platform
solutions we have and think about which
ones fit because in many cases i think
is why she is going to describe it's not
just one tool that will solve
our goal but it's multiple tools that
she's going to call on so if you have an
idea faculty member again the college or
any the professional schools that
doesn't fit into a Coursera or an open
EDX please contact craig in myself and
we'd love to talk to you about these
solutions that are at our disposal so
why cheat welcome you to come on up and
talk about your idea